Lola James was a little ray of sunshine
her father says she was beautiful
charming and cheeky she died of a
catastrophic brain injury inflicted by
her mother's new partner
Kyle Bevin left Lola with more than a
hundred separate injuries as he was
jailed for her murder the judge said
he'd shown no remorse this was a
sustained deliberate and very violent
attack
he sentenced Bevin to life in prison the
attack would have caused both mental and
physical pain and suffering before the
onset of coma
it was the culmination of several months
of physical child abuse
Lola's mother SHINee James tried to hide
her face as she arrived at court she was
jailed for six years the judge said
she'd prioritized her relationship with
Bevin over concern for her daughter
she'd let Bevin move into her squalid
home in pembrokeshire as the country
went into the first national lockdown
within five months Lola was dead
Bevin showed no reaction in the dark as
the judge detailed the horrific attack
that happened overnight as Lola fell
unconscious Bevin took photos and even a
video of her and instead of calling for
help he spent time washing Lola and
cleaning the house to try to cover up
what he'd done he lied that she'd been
pushed down the stairs by the dog when
Lola's mother woke up she called an
ambulance
just to convey this she conscious
is she conscious I didn't
be really scared
Lola's father was in court to see Bevin
and James jailed in a statement he said
I miss Lola and my heart hurts her tiny
body was Savaged in the evilest way she
didn't stand a chance all I have been
left with is guilt heartache pain and
torment
Lola and her family had previously been
referred to Social Services a review
will now establish if more could have
been done to save her Becky Johnson Sky
News at Swansea Crown Court